vielleicht hast du schon mal auf einer
party erlebt du lernst jemanden kennen
den du noch nie zuvor gesehen hast aber
nach einiger zeit findet ihr heraus dass
ihr beide denselben freund kennt der
wiederum nichts mit der party zu tun hat
ach ja in was für einer kleinen welt
wieder aufleben
aber lasst uns die sache mal auf den
grund gehen wie klein ist unsere welt
genau
diese frage führt uns recht weit zurück
ins jahr 1929 wo der ungarische
schriftsteller karen ti eine
kurzgeschichte veröffentlichte chains
handelt von einem charakter der eine
wette aufstellt kann man ihm eine person
nennen die er nicht über fünf oder
weniger zwischen kontakte erreichen
könnte der gedanke des verbunden sein
wird sogar noch weiter gesponnen und
jetzt mit überlegt ob nicht nur personen
sondern wirklich alles miteinander
verbunden ist zum beispiel eine teekanne
mit einem stein im marianengraben und
das über maximal fünf schritte die
kurzgeschichte wurde zu einer zeit
geschrieben in der der exponentielle
fortschritt die welt immer näher
zusammenrückt eisenbahn telegramm
automobil telefon und radio
kommunikation und transport wurden immer
schneller und immer weitreichender in
diesem sinne traf die kurzgeschichte den
zahlen der zeit aber wie sieht es
eigentlich heute aus sind wir inzwischen
dich noch viel weiter im internet kann
ich innerhalb von sekunden über ein
drittel der menschheit erreichen und mit
dem flugzeug bin ich innerhalb eines
tages überall auf der erdkugel sind wir
also wirklich alle miteinander verbunden
kenne ich über fünf kontakte jennifer
lawrence barack obama oder bill gates
höchstwahrscheinlich ja nur mit dem
kleinen problem dass der letzte kontakt
uns nie im leben die handynummer an
dieser leute weitergeben würde aber
berühmte menschen sind in dieser
hinsicht eigentlich noch die einfachsten
menschen die lernen jeden tag neue leute
kennen und reisen um die welt und jeder
weiß auch dass die cousine von leonardo
dicaprio mal auf der schule eines
freundes war oder so ähnlich nein was
ist wirklich bedeutet wenn man mit jedem
menschen über fünf kontakte verbunden
ist ist dass du auch irgendeinen
peruanischen friseur einen chinesischen
obdachlosen oder jeden einzelnen
australischen farmer kennst ist unsere
welt wirklich so vernetzt um das zu
überprüfen mussten wissenschaftler erst
einmal herausfinden wie wir
untereinander vernetzt sind
sie wollten ein system bauen dass die
echte welt simuliert und dafür gibt es
zwei wichtige faktoren
das clustering und den durchmesser
clustering beschreibt wie stark die
gruppenbildung in einem system ist zwei
meiner freunde haben zum beispiel eine
sehr hohe wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
sich auch untereinander kennen denn
viele dinge in unserem sozialen leben
rotieren heutzutage um unsere interessen
herum mein freundeskreis besteht zu
großen teilen aus menschen die am
gleichen arbeitsplatz arbeiten das
gleiche hobby haben oder politisch
ähnlich denken also ist das clustering
in einem system das die echte welt
simuliert sehr hoch man lebt in gruppen
in denen sich die meisten menschen
untereinander kennen und ähnliche
interessen haben
der zweite wichtige faktor ist der
durchmesser eines systems über wie viele
stationen geht der längste weg zwischen
zwei menschen und das sind im
durchschnitt interessanterweise recht
wenige aber wie geht das zusammen
auf der einen seite die gruppenbildung
in der menschen sich größtenteils mit
den engen freunden und gleichgesinnten
aufhalten und auf der anderen seite ein
kleiner durchmesser der alle menschen
eines systems sehr schnell miteinander
verbindet hier fanden die
wissenschaftler eines heraus short
chains lange verbindungen zwischen zwei
knotenpunkten sind das wichtigste für
ein solches system
sie verbinden weite strecken zwischen
zwei kontakten und senken so den
durchschnitt der benötigten
zwischenstationen für alle menschen das
sind zum beispiel leute die du aus dem
urlaub kennst vom schüleraustausch oder
über den arbeitskollegen aus amerika je
mehr short chains es gibt desto
vernetzter ist ein system auch und so
etwas nennt man dann ein kleine welt
netzwerk dieses phänomen ist auch der
grund warum du von diesem weiter
entfernten menschen
vielmehr profitieren kannst als von
deinen freunden stell dir vor du bist
auf der suche nach einem neuen job deine
freunde und bekannte wissen im zweifel
nicht viel mehr als du selber sie
arbeiten schon bei dir am arbeitsplatz
haben dieselben freunde die du auf hass
und sie lesen dieselbe zeitung weil sie
die gleichen interessen haben wie du
selber ein entfernter bekannter von ihr
hingegen hat einen komplett anderen
hintergrund
er lebt in einem anderen sozialen umfeld
und kennt ganz andere menschen
er hat eine viel höhere chance den weg
zu deinem neuen chef zu verkürzen
okay soweit zur theorie der
wissenschaftler es gibt ein paar punkte
die man an diesem system kritisieren
könnte wie immer eigentlich wenn man
versucht die echte welt zu simulieren
zum beispiel dass das clustering so
stark ist schließlich füllen wir alle in
unserem alltag verschiedenen rollen aus
und haben oft mehrere freundeskreise die
kollegen von der arbeit meiner alten
schulfreunde und die jungs vom
tennisverein schon drei verschiedene
gruppen die eigentlich nichts
miteinander zu tun haben und schott
saints sind auch brüchige als man
zugeben möchte der typ mit dem ich vor
drei jahren im urlaub immer surfen
gegangen bin und den ich dann auf
facebook ad habe kann sich vielleicht
gar nicht mehr an mich erinnern
und selbst wenn dann ist das ziemlich
fraglich ob er mir mal eben so einen job
besorgen will
aber das tolle am internet ist ja dass
wir es nicht simulieren müssen sondern
dass die klicks freunde und laiz einfach
zählen können und sascha berg sei dank
facebook hat es getan
im februar 2016 hat facebook seine
datenbanken analysiert und
herausgefunden dass die 16 milliarden
facebook nutzer im durchschnitt durch
nur 35 kontakte miteinander verbunden
werden können und diese zahl sinkt
stetig während sowohl facebook
nutzerzahlen als auch die
durchschnittliche anzahl von freunden
steigt auch hier kann man facebook nicht
so wirklich mit dem echten leben
vergleichen schließlich gibt es so
manche menschen die wir zwar kennen aber
nicht möglich auf facebook zum beispiel
chefs oder lehrer aber das spielt ja
eigentlich dem argument der vernetztheit
nur weiter in die arme hingegen gibt es
vielleicht so manche leute die
wildfremde menschen auf facebook enden
die sie eigentlich gar nicht kennen
aber diesen menschen kann man ja dann
eine nachricht schreiben und das ist ja
irgendwie die definition von vernetzt
sein dass man mit ihnen verbunden ist
aber wartet mal verbunden sind wir
sowieso alle
wir haben vielleicht nicht mehr zu jedem
direkten kontakt aber wir sind alle
miteinander verwandt
nein im ernst wir beide sind miteinander
verwandt
lasst es mich kurz erklären wenn du
deinen stammbaum zurückverfolgt und mit
rechnet dass du zwei eltern hass und
sowohl deine mutter als auch der vater
jeweils zwei eltern haben und auch diese
vier menschen jeweils für eltern hatten
dann erreicht danach 37 generationen
eine zahl die größer ist als alle
menschen die jemals auf der erde gelebt
haben was grob geschätzt 100 8
milliarden menschen waren was mal ganz
nebenbei echt wenig ist im vergleich zu
den sieben milliarden menschen die jetzt
gerade leben das ist gerade mal das
14fache aber gut zurück zum thema vor 37
generationen waren wir ganz grob
geschätzt in der ersten jahrtausendwende
nach christus
zehntausende jahre nachdem es die ersten
menschen gab was bedeutet dass wir rein
rechnerisch alle miteinander verwandt
sein müssen
und höchstwahrscheinlich haben wir sogar
alle einen gemeinsamen vorfahren mit dem
wir alle verwandt sind und
wissenschaftler versuchen ständig ihn zu
finden
eine aktuelle studie kommt zu dem
schluss dass dieser letzte gemeinsame
vorfahre vor zirka 2300 jahren im
ostasiatischen raum gelebt haben könnte
wahrscheinlich in einer hafenstadt in
der seine kinder sich schnell in die
ganze welt verbreiten konnten
die studie deutet auch darauf hin dass
der letzte gemeinsame vorfahre immer
jünger wird die globalisierter und
vernetzter unsere welt wird in gewisser
weise kennst du also wirklich jeden
menschen auf der welt und wie ich in
dieser folge erklärt habe besteht sogar
aus atomen die man anderen menschen
gehört haben es ist wirklich alles
miteinander verbunden
viel spaß dabei und nicht solch nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin fertig